haskell a statically typed
general-purpose language made famous for
expanding the minds of developers into
the functional programming paradigm you
see haskell is a purely functional
language based on lambda calculus which
means a function always produces the
same output given the same input unlike
an imperative language your code can't
modify the inputs or produce side
effects that would otherwise change the
behavior of the application it was first
developed in 1987 and named after
logician haskell curry whose work had a
massive influence on the functional
programming world it's been used to
build a wide variety of server-side
applications like the hasura api
platform spam filtering at facebook and
compilers for other languages like elm
and purescript and it's responsible for
a countless number of blog posts about
monads in haskell you write declarative
code where the program is a single
expression that is executed by
evaluating that expression it also uses
lazy evaluation which means an
expression is not evaluated until it's
actually used by a function this can
result in big performance gains but
unpredictable memory use at runtime all
data in a haskell program is immutable
which produces a lot of memory garbage
so it contains a garbage collector to
clean things up to get started install
the glasgow haskell compiler then create
a file ending in dot hs we don't work
with statements here only expressions
which is code that will always evaluate
to a value create a string with double
quotes then give it a name with the
equal sign the value is immutable and
can never be changed the type will
automatically be inferred or we can
strongly type it with a double colon as
a list of characters now to define a
function start with a name followed by
the arguments that you want to pass to
it on the right side define the logic of
the function and it will automatically
return a value based on the result of
the expression we can also statically
type it using an arrow to separate the
argument and return value we can call
the function by referencing its name
with the arguments all values including
functions are first class which means
they can be passed as arguments to other
functions if we try to print the result
to the standard output we get an error
that's because working with io creates a
side effect to write a program that
actually does something we write a main
function with a do block here we can
chain together a sequence of actions
where the side effects are abstracted
away made possible by a mathematical
concept known as the monad which is
basically a wrapper that can make
functional code more modular now to run
your code you can use the interactive
interpreter or compile it to an
executable by running ghc make this has
been haskell in 100 seconds hit the like
button and subscribe if you want to see
more short videos like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one